in the late 90s Matthew Lillard was
slashing his way into the big-time with
memorable appearances and scream hackers
and she's all that but before he ever
managed to hit the a-list his big-screen
career seemed to fizzle out while he
hasn't quite vanished from the film
scene
he certainly endured his fair share of
cinematic setbacks so why did Lillard
star status seem to drop so fast here's
why you don't hear much about Matthew
Lillard these days in the shadow of Stu
Lillard is probably best remembered for
his turn as Stu the sidekick killer in
Wes Craven's 1996 classic screen by then
the actor had already turned some heads
with his oddball presence in the 1995
cyber drama hackers but he stole so many
scenes in screen with his goofy scare
tactics that his appeal was undeniable
see we asked you a question
get it all oh yeah the downside of
itching that character in viewers
memories though is that he struggled to
establish a screen identity outside of
the role and since dude died in the
first film it's not like he could return
for any of its sequels let's face it
baby these days you gotta have a sequel
Willard admitted to the a/v Club that
even two decades later he's still being
asked about Stu and said talking about
scream is like talking about the first
girl you ever kissed he added that he
finds the continued attention to the
role bizarre and said that he really
doesn't understand why it's held such a
place in horror fans his heart's alright
I feel Rosie yeah but that's not the
only role that's lingered in lillard
life long live shaggy after screen
Lillard went on to star in several roles
that continued to showcase his signature
scene eNOS like his dance happy dirtbag
role and she's all that and nasty though
the punk rock fan and SLC punk the movie
that really set his career into slower
motion though was 2002 scooby-doo
Lillard played the peculiar pet owner
shaggy in the live-action film and it's
2004 sequel but even after that movie
franchise ended shaggy just stuck with
him
for the main course
Lillard credited the films with being
the biggest momentum killer of his
career because it took his indie credit
and threw it out the window but he's
also been able to count on the
subsequent mini movies animated TV
series and video games featuring the
character for steady paychecks in fact
Lillard admitted if it wasn't for
scooby-doo I wouldn't still be in
California acting I'd be somewhere else
doing something else
scooby-doo the movie saved my bacon to
be honest and it still does that show is
still around and it's the constant job I
have and I love doing the voice even so
he's still an ensemble member in that
series which is something he knows all
about wingman central with few
exceptions Matthew Lillard has almost
always been cast as the standout psychic
character in his movies especially when
they involve his once frequent co-star
Freddie Prinze jr. in fact Lillard
starred alongside prints in a whopping
five films including she's all that
Wing Commanders summer catch and both
scooby-doo movies their on and off
screen bromance might have worked well
for a while but even Lillard thinks it's
got to be overkill around the fourth
collaboration he once dubbed himself guy
who was in a Freddie Prinze jr. movie
too many and has vowed that the pair
won't be seen together on screen again
red yo-yo later on he didn't gain the
reputation of being Prince's second
banana by design of course but those few
films which have given him a chance of
the lead have been kind of regrettable
he dropped some real talk in an
interview with The AV Club saying the
more lines I have in general the worse
in movie is it's very rare that I get to
say great things in fantastic movies so
if you see me as like number one on the
call sheet in general that movie is
pretty bad
speaking of which certified run Lillard
is gone back and forth over which film
ranks his absolute worst he's pointed to
both in the name of the king a Dungeon
Siege tale and home run showdown as some
cringe-worthy installments on his resume
but critics have had a field day panning
his pictures his 1998 comedy horror film
dead man's curve got a giant goose egg
of a Rotten Tomatoes
then there was senseless which lived up
to its own name and earned just 6% on
the site all told there have been
another half dozen of his films that
earned scathing reviews while Lillard
has starred in a few films that critics
liked including Alexander Payne's 2011
hit The Descendants and his own 2012
directorial effort fat kid rules the
world the vast majority of his movies
have been major critical misses missing
the teen beat despite some early
popularity and good looks Matthew
Lillard wasn't ever really deemed a
heartthrob of the teen magazine scene
while actors like Leonardo DiCaprio
Jonathan Taylor Thomas and Josh Hartnett
were literal poster boys of the team
beat era
Lillard wasn't tapped for the same kind
of adoration because of that he's never
been promoted to leading man status or
given a rom-com role worth swooning over
he did have a romantic arc in 2004's
without a paddle but that was a buddy
comedy first and foremost and the bad
one at that
considering how crucial that's been in
other successful careers in show
business it's a bummer small screen
surprises one field where Matthew
Lillard has had some luck is on the
television circuit not only was he a
series regular on FX this ambitious
crime drama the bridge but he's also
appeared on state of affairs The Good
Wife and halt and catch fire
he's also among the impressive cast of
TV's Twin Peaks revival due to debut in
2017 and revealed that his character in
the show will be epic moral of the story
he might not be a marquee name at the
local theater but TV is giving him some
meat to chew on with his performances
just another beautiful day in paradise
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and watch more videos like the one you
just saw and don't forget to check out
all this cool stuff we know you'll love
to